وقع لبنان وقطر الملحقين التعديليين
لاتفاقيه استكشافي واستخراج النفط والغاز
في المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه للبنان
وجرى التوقيع برعايه رئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي وحضور وزير
الدوله لشؤون الطاقه القطريه سعد بن شريد
الكعبي والغيره اللبناني وليد فياض
دوله قطر عبر شركه قطر الطاقه الى تحالف
التنقيب عن النفط الذي يضم قطان الفرنسيه
اربعه
شركه قطر للطاقه التي حلتانه شركه نوفاتيك
الروسيه على 30% بينما تحصل كل من تطال
وان هي على خمسه
معنى من السرايا الحكومي في بيروت مراسل
الجزيره جوني ايطاليوس جوني المزيد عن هذه
الاتفاقيه وخاصه
الجوانب التي تم تعديلها في اتفاقيتين
مما لا شك فيها عبد الصمد ان لبنان ينظر
بكثير من الايجابيه والتفاؤل الى انضمام
شركه قطر للطاقه الى هذا التحالف المعني
بالتنقيب عن النفطي والغاز في المياه
اللبنانيه ولبنان يتطلع بشكل كبير الى
العائدات الممكنه من عمليات الاستكشاف
وانتاج النفط والغاز في المياه الاقتصاديه
اللبنانيه من اجل التعامل مع ازماتها
الاقتصاديه والماليه وهذه الايجابيه عبر
عنها بشكل واضح رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
نجيب ميقاتي الذي وصف هذه الخطوه بالحدث
الاستثنائي وقال ان انضمام شركه قطر
للطاقه الى تحالف شركتي اني وتوتال همم
يعكس عمرك تعاون اللبنانيه القطري ويفتح
المجال امام اطراف عربيه وخليجيه من اجل
الاستثمار في لبنان حفل التوقيع تم برعايه
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال وفي حضور
الرئيسين التنفيذيين لشركاتي وهو تم
بطبيعه الحال بين كانت الطاقه اللبنانيه
من جهه وشركه قطر للطاقه من جهه ثانيه
ممثله بوزير الطاقه القطري لشؤون الطاقه
سعد الكعبي وتحدث الكعبي عن ان هذا
الانضمام القطري الى عمليات التنقيب عن
النفط والغاز يدعم التنميه الاقتصاديه في
لبنان وان قطر حاضره دائما الى جانب الشعب
اللبناني كما تحدث وزير الطاقه في حكومه
تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه وليد فياض عن ان
هذا التحالف بين الشركات الثلاث همم يعكس
الثقه الموجوده في لبنان ردا على سؤال
للجزيره للوزيرين اللبناني والقطري عن
افاق التعاون الممكنه اكد الجانبان ان
هناك همم اتفاقيات او تعاونا ممكنا في
المستقبل بشان الطاقه المتجدده لمساعده
لبنان في مشاكله المختلفه واهمها طبعا
الكهرباء اذا ما اردنا ان نتحدث تقنيه
التعديلات التي ترى على الاتفاقيتين
لموقعتين هي متعلقه اولا بانضمام قطر
للطاقه الى التحالف والثانيه المتعلقه
بنسب الحصص الحصه التي كانت همم استحوذت
عليها شركه نوفا تك الروسيه كانت 20% طبعا
حلت شركه قطر للطاقه مكان شركه نظافتك
الروسيه لكنها استحوذت ايضا على ما نسبته
5% من كل من توتال وانا وبالتالي باتت
حصتها الاجماليه في هذا التحالف 30%
والحصه الباقيه موزعه على شركتين همم
الاخرتين وطبعا بحسب ما يقول المسؤولون
اللبنانيون في الاشهر المقبله ستتكسف
عمليات الاستكشاف والحفر وتحديدا في بلوك
رقم او الرقعه البحريه رقم تسعه وهي
موجوده الى عند الحدود الجنوبيه همم
اللبنانيه همم بالاضافه طبعا الى عمليات
الاستكشاف التي تسبق عمليات همم الحفر
طبعا لا ارقام واضحه بشان العائدات
المرتقبه والمنتظر من الاستكشاف والحفر
هناك تقديرات قد تصدر في المرحله المقبله
بناءا على الاعمال التي تقوم بها همم
الشركات الثلاث كما قال الرؤساء
التنفيذيون في هذه الشركات الحاضره
وبالتالي من المتوقع ان تبدا عمليات الحفر
بشكل مكثف في شهر اكتوبر المقبل وتنتهي
قبل نهايه العام الحالي وعندها طبعا يمكن
الركن الى ارقام دقيقه اذا بشكل رسمي بات-
قطر للطاقه الشريك كان في عمليات التنقيب
والاستكشاف وانتاج النفط والغاز في المياه
اللبنانيه طبعا هناك مراحل تنفيذيه بشان
استجلاب الحفارات وهي حفارات موجوده في
عدد من المناطق من اجل العمل وكما ذكرت في
بدايه هذه الرساله التعويل اللبنانيه كبير
على انضمام قطر للطاقه الى هذا التحالف
وعلى عمليات الاستكشاف والانتاج بشكل عام
شكرا لك همم جوني جوني مراسيل الجزيره من
بيروت شكرا